[Музика]
привіт, чудової ночі, мене звати Анна, і
сьогодні урок англійської мови ми
закінчили розмову про молодіжну культуру, і у
нас є повторний урок, тож давайте почнемо
з перегляду словникового запасу, який насправді
був частиною  ваше домашнє завдання на
сьогодні, тож давайте подивимося,
щоб ви могли згадати слова з нашого
підрозділу, подивіться на слова тут
модниця — це людина, якій дуже
подобається мода, спільнота, це
група людей з однаковими інтересами,
впевненість у собі, це відчуття  що ти можеш
зробити все, щоб бути впевненим у собі,
що таке тренд, чи пам’ятаєш, що це
слово пов’язане з модою, тож
це модний тренд, який ми використовуємо як
фразу, щоб говорити про речі, які
дуже популярні в модному стилі життя, що
насправді  тип життя, який ви ведете,
це може бути здоровий спосіб життя, це може бути
нездоровий спосіб життя, він може бути активним або
пасивним, тож як щодо наступного
марнотратника ми б назвали людину
марнотратником, якщо ця людина витрачає  багато
грошей на одяг як щодо книжкового хробака
ви пам'ятаєте книжковий хробак - це людина,
яка любить читати, тому ця людина
читає багато книг, що таке одяг
, є крихітне маленьке слово
посередині, це насправді набір одягу,
який ви  носити хобі це вид
дозвілля, який людям подобається робити
речі. Це слово це слово, яке
означає щось одне, наприклад, одна
культура, яка є специфічною культурою,
яка не є звичайною не величезною загальною
культурою, але це культура деяких
спільноти, тож це крихітний
розтратник субкультури насправді є синонімом
слова марнотратник, тому людина, яка витрачає
багато грошей на товари та одяг, переважно
культ, чи пам’ятаєте ви, що це означає,
насправді це рух людей, які люблять
робити щось поважне, тож це
відчуття ніби в когось так сильно, що тобі
добре до них і ти добре
ставишся
до цих людей, молодь насправді це
частина назви нашого підрозділу, тому молодь
означає підлітка  s або молоді люди
наступне слово є унікальним ми використовуємо його, щоб говорити
про щось особливе у своєму
роді наступне дивне синонім до
слова дивний був би дивний незвичайний
рух, який насправді є масовою
діяльністю людей, тому люди роблять
щось, що є  дійсно впливовий
наступний культура останній, але один
це деякі особливості
особливості спільнот, тому останнє слово
- бутик це магазин
модного одягу, зазвичай досить
дорогий, зараз, коли
ми переглянули слова, давайте поглянемо
на  головоломка зі словами, тож скільки слів
ви можете знайти за одну хвилину, подивіться
, де це 12, і праворуч ви
можете побачити головоломку про молодіжну культуру на нашу
тему, тож слова можуть бути хрестиком
або також  діагональ, тож тепер у
вас є одна хвилина, щоб знайти
слова в цій головоломці
[Музика]
добре, через одну хвилину давайте подивимося
на дошку, і ви можете перевірити себе,
щоб тут ми могли знайти слова, і ось
як t  гей, організовані в головоломку зі словами,
тож скільки слів ви знайшли, чи
було це складно, я думаю, що за одну хвилину
це було досить складно. Гаразд, тепер
давайте перейдемо до іншої частини, ми
збираємося прочитати короткий текст, і після цього тексту
вам доведеться  дайте відповіді на запитання,
щоб текст був про хіпі, це
насправді субкультура, яка була популярна
в 1960-х у 1970-х роках минулого
століття, тож давайте читати й слухати яппі,
рейв-рокери Тедді хлопчики, гранж до
кінця 1960-х з’явилася нова субкультура
хіпі було  Спочатку
рух, який виник у США та
поширився на інші країни
світу, рух хіпі базувався
на концепції невідповідності соціальним
моделям
та ніжній анархії, ранні хіпі
створювали власні спільноти, відвідували
музичні фестивалі під відкритим небом та слухали
психоделію.  рок, вони ходили по магазинах на
розпродажі та благодійні магазини, давно
викинуті військова форма та етнічні
сукні змішували та поєднували їх, щоб створити
унікальний вул.  yle музика була приправлена
ітичними посланнями, які пропагують мир і лю
ов. Мода та цінності хіпі мали ве
икий вплив на культуру та мистецтво з 1960-
років, багато аспектів культури хіпі бу
и засвоєні основним су
пільством, так що тепер ми знаємо тр
хи більше про су
культуру  хіпі ми готові перевірити, наскільки добре
ви пам'ятаєте факти з тексту, і
тут у нас є запитання, тож чи є
твердження правдивими чи неправдивими, подивіться
номер один хіпі з'явилися у
Великобританії, чи це правильне те, що було
країна, де з'явилися хіпі,
це була не Великобританія, а США, тому
це речення хибне
номер два. Хіпі жили серед подібних
людей, чи жили хіпі у своїх власних
спільнотах, чи вони жили з іншими
людьми, які не є хіпі, так,
насправді вони так жили  тому вони жили
з подібними людьми з хіпі, тому вони
створили власні спільноти, це
твердження, як ви бачите, є правдивим номером
3, на якому рух хіпі був заснований на
гідному б  поведінка і гармонія тому, коли ми
говоримо про хіпі і поведінку, що
це означає гідне, що насправді
українською ми будемо використовувати слово
вечірній стиль, це правда
добре насправді ми знаємо, що
він був якийсь неслухняний, а вони
були досить бунтарські тому цей факт
насправді це неправда, тому вони точно
не стосувалися гарної поведінки,
наступний номер четвертий —
мода і цінності хіпі
на даний момент повністю вимерли, тож чи правда, що
хіпі більше немає, і
фактично немає жодного впливу, який вони зробили
на  сьогоднішня культура і
суспільство,
насправді, цей факт безсумнівно
хибний, ми все ще маємо певний вплив
хіпі, які пропагують мир і любов, головна
ідея полягала в тому, що одна, тож ми продовжуємо
дотримуватись її тут сьогодні, а
хіпі номер п’ять були військова форма та
етнічний одяг, тому що вони  хотіли
створити свій власний стиль, чи це правда
, якщо вони фактично використовували військову
форму в одязі у своєму
вбранні  користуючись етнічним одягом,
так, звичайно, цей факт вірний,
вони носили військову форму та
етнічний одяг, і вони дійсно хотіли
створити свій особистий стиль хіпі,
добре, тепер, коли
ми переглянули словниковий запас і
трохи зміцнилися, давайте перейдемо до  деяка редакція
, а також інша частина нашої ревізії, тому
ця одиниця ми говорили про герундій,
який насправді і зараз і складається
з дієслова
шляхом додавання ing so замість to read у нас бу
е читання, і це буде ін
а форма слова so  to read
plus ing — це читати, щоб плавати, плюс ing,
плавати і так далі.
Сподіваюся, ви пам’ятаєте цю інформацію,
і тут у нас є кілька прикладів, які ми могли
побачити на одному з наших попередніх уроків,
давайте поглянемо та швидко переглянемо
читання, щоб допомогти вам навчитися  Англійська, її
улюблене хобі –
я люблю читати, тому тут ви можете побачити,
що слово читання, яке є герундієм,
функціонує як суб’єкт або об’єкт.
Корнелл фанк про
Піта Мета Ніка Шавона проти Корі-молодшого.
про темне ооооооооооооооооооо Кінсі Регіна,
а також є деякі додаткові правила
щодо використання герундію, звичайно,
першим є підмет іменника, який ми щойно
бачили, а потім номер два після
прийменника, наприклад, я втомився чекати
на тебе або  він дуже добре танцює і
так далі, тому крихітні слова, такі як off
from with in add і так далі,
це прийменники після них, ми
зазвичай використовуємо
наступне число три, звичайно
, це тепер останнє правило, але це
просто  коротка редакція виразів,
тому є деякі вирази, які нам
просто потрібно запам’ятати або
віруси Джованні Талавера II зараз президент
фітнес-додаток Amiata показує деякі з фільмів про нік,
проклята плита з авокадо ммм,
вітаю, немає офіційного ing, наприклад,
немає сенсу щось робити це  нічого доброго
робити і так далі,
добре, тепер давайте потренуємося і перевіримо,
наскільки добре ви запам’ятали структури, наше
завдання – завершити
речення герранами, утвореними з інфінітивів
у дужках, тому  номер один уряд
заохочує переробляти, тому переробляти це
дієслово recycle тут інфінітив і
як ми будемо робити ing як ми будемо
робити герундій, який насправді
буде використовуватися тут у вигляді
об'єкта дона моча частинка майстер Будда
haroon geophone sidqa, так, я думаю
, що ви вже зрозуміли, що
це переробка, уряд заохочує
переробку,
добре, тепер номер два
вона втомилася мити посуд щовечора
тут у нас є прийменник + герундій, і
ми скажемо, що вона втомилася  миючи
посуд щовечора наступного номеру
три, він зрозумів, що вона так скоро пішла, тому
тут ми будемо використовувати форму ing не
забувайте, що буква e в кінці вилучена,
тому слово «їде» є VI ng він
зрозумів, що вона йде так  незабаром
четвертий
він пішов на рибалку з батьком, якщо ми додамо,
це буде мода, тому він пішов на
рибалку номер п'ять, він боїться
скласти тест, тому нам потрібно додати ing to take,
і це буде він боятися
складати тест все  правильно молодці, ми
пройшли половину цієї вправи, тепер давайте
перейдемо до номеру шість
Келлі запропонувала відвезти нас додому,
тому Келлі запропонувала відвезти нас додому
номер сім, її реакція на отримання
Оскара була трохи дивною,
тому її реакція на перемогу тут у нас
буде подвійною  n у слові в слові
winning і це герундій, який,
до речі, вживається після прийменника до
числа вісім, він заперечував take the car, тому
після деяких дієслів ми будемо використовувати ing,
тому ми скажемо, що він заперечував взяти машину
номер дев'ять
Рассел був збентежений тим, що не виграв у
цьому матчі, і останній номер
десятий, Шейла почне працювати там наступного
тижня, тому Шейла почне працювати там
наступного тижня, добре зробила цю
вправу, тепер ми щойно згадали, як
створювати форми ing  слова, і
давайте подивимося на
слова, у яких насправді використовується герундій після
них, їм потрібен герундій або їм
потрібен інфінітив після них,
тому, звичайно, це не всі дієслова
, після яких буде герундій або
infin  Звичайно, їх набагато більше,
але це лише список, який ми
вже вивчили, тому давайте переглянемо дієслово
плюс герундій, ми фактично визнаємо, що робити
щось може стояти насолоду, відмовитися від ненависті
почати або замислитися робити щось, тому після
цих слів ми будемо використовувати інше
стовпець дієслово + інфінітив після цих
дієслів ми будемо використовувати 2 + дієслово, наприклад,
вирішити зробити щось забути зробити
щось потрібно відмовитися спробувати хочу і
хотів би зробити щось добре, тепер давайте
подивимося на вправу, і наше завдання -
вибрати правильний  пункт для практики
номер один сертифікаційна програма
вимагає від мене скласти або пройти кілька
тестів, тому що ми будемо використовувати після дієслова
require to require або requires, оскільки воно
вживається тут, звичайно, ми будемо використовувати
інфінітив, тому вимагає від мене пройти
кілька тестів наступного  Я сказав іншим
зустрітися або зустрітися зі мною на пляжі після
роботи, чому б тобі не прийти, так що
після дієслова to tell what will be used
Звичайно інфінітив ще раз
перейдемо до номер три Робін  спонукав
мене взяти участь або взяти участь
у 24-годинному танцювальному марафоні,
тому спонукав мене взяти участь або
взяти участь, що ви думаєте,
звичайно, тут ми будемо використовувати ing навів
мене взяти участь під
номером чотири він цінував, що ми допомогли або
ми йому допомогли  підготуйся до
вечірки на Хеллоуїн що ми будемо використовувати
після дієслова appreciate, яка форма
дієслова так цінує нас або to help або our
helping here ceniте нашу допомогу
номер п'ять, щоб піти або стрибнути з парашутом
завтра ми перевіримо, наскільки ви сміливі,
так що йти  або going here ми маємо це дієслово
на початку речення, тому ми
припускаємо, що це підмет або трохи
вище основного враження e, тому нам
потрібно використовувати форму ing дієслова
герундію тут, так що завтра стрибки з парашутом
номер шість don  вам не потрібно робити або
робити перерву, ви працюєте
без перерви понад вісім годин, тому яка
форма do, яка тут, звичайно,
має бути інфінітивом після дієслова need, який
ми будемо використовувати для плюс дієслова so don't  вам
потрібно зробити перерву
номер сім, щоб прибути, інакше наше
запізнення було б образою для наших
господарів обіду, що, на вашу думку, ми маємо
вибрати тут, це знову
початок речення, ймовірно,
це тема, тому ми розуміємо, що це
бути ing, тому наше
пізно прибуття було б образою для наших господарів вечері,
наступного передостаннього
номеру вісім, але був схвильований
зустріччю або зустріч із всесвітньо відомим
фотографом, так схвильований зустріччю або
схвильований від зустрічі з чим  Як ви думаєте,
тут у нас є прийменник про, після
якого ми будемо використовувати герундій, тому вона була в
захваті від зустрічі номер дев'ять, як
йому вдалося отримати або отримати квитки
на
той концерт, він був розпроданий
місяцями,
так що ми використовуємо після  дієслово to
manage is it to plus інфінітив або
ing yeah прямо тут ми будемо використовувати
інфінітив, тож ми скажемо, що як вам
вдалося отримати квитки на той концерт
, і тут все добре, тепер давайте
подивимося на інші  слова, за якими йде
або герундій, або інфінітив, тому з
нашого попереднього уроку на одному з попередніх
уроків ви можете згадати ці
списки дієслів, давайте подивимося на них
ще раз, щоб дієслова, за якими
йде герундій, тобто дієслово плюс
ing, були  у першому рядку заперечувати
згадати уявіть терпіти розуміти
включати повний звіт передбачити
відкликання та дозволити, тому ці слова
супроводжуються ing або герундієм ре
ти слів у другій частині за ними йд
ть 2 плюс інфінітив, тому такі сл
ва, як очікують щось зробити  намір
прикидатися відмовлятися так і так далі, щоб
вирішити щось зробити, ці дієслова
супроводжуються інфінітивом to + дієсловом ok,
тепер давайте попрактикуємося, наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
вибрати правильний пункт номер один, який він
очікує закінчити, або завершити
навчання наступного літа, тому
ми очікуємо закінчення чи очікуємо закінчити,
яку форму дієслова нам потрібно буде
використати після дієслова очікувати, що
буде інфінітивом Звичайно очікує
закінчити  Посадові особи національного парку номер два
не дозволяють входити або
заходити в парк без офіційного гіда,
тому ми щойно бачили це слово Дарем,
що це те, що ми використовуємо, щоб слідувати, це
герундій або до плюс інфінітив, звичайно,
ми будемо використовувати герундій  ось,
увійшовши до наступної,
він запропонував нести її книги
по дорозі додому, ми пропонуємо
щось зробити чи ми пропонуємо зробити щось
після дієслова offer, який ми звикли до плюс
інфінітив, тому він запропонував нести її
книги наступну  археолог
повідомив про знахідку або про те, щоб знайти велику
раніше невідому піраміду глибоко в
джунглях, тож ми повідомляємо про те, що робимо щось
або робимо звіт, щоб щось зробити, звичайно,
тут ми будемо використовувати форму з ing нормально
номер п'ять Саманта
постійно забуває або забуває надіслати нам
документи, які ми повинні мати їх до
наступного тижня, щоб вона постійно забула або вона
постійно забувала, яку форму
дієслова правильно використовувати після дієслова to keep
check yourself, звичайно, це ing
keep doing something  вона постійно
забуває, вона продовжує забути про це,
і номер шостий
Фелікс вирішив не погодитися або прийняти
їхню позицію в Маямі, тому що він
хотів залишитися в Нью-Йорку.
частинка не, як ви
бачите, відразу після дієслова вирішити, тому
вирішити насправді слід два плюс
інфінітив давайте перевіримо вирішили не
приймати, будь ласка, зверніть увагу, що якщо у вас
є негативний інфінітив,
частка not стоятиме прямо перед 2
плюс інфінітивом shonas
інфінітив заперечний означає середній у моїй
нижній частині Шабату діє на
цнотливість Co зараз,
але у деяких жінок finit even piss la
Astana Hajus lava Madonna mobile pod Co
вирішила не і потім плюс дієслово добре
номер сім зараз
тренується і їсть або займатися спортом
і  Правильне харчування може допомогти вам прожити довге
і здорове життя, тож що ми будемо використовувати
тут: інфінітив чи форму ing,
звичайно, це початок  У
реченні нам потрібно використовувати підмет
із герундію, воно почнеться речення, тому
ми скажемо, що фізичні вправи та
правильне харчування можуть допомогти вам жити довгим і
здоровим життям, і останнє речення
тут номер вісім, яким біженці ризикували
бути або стати  захоплені, коли вони намагаються
втекти через свої коні,
що буде тут, яка форма
слова ing або інфінітив, тому
після дієслова to risk ми будемо використовувати ing,
звичайно, так що вони біженці ризикують бути
схоплені, коли намагаються втекти
через гори
добре зроблено чудову роботу, так що це
все на сьогодні, у вас не буде
домашнього завдання наступного разу,
тому що наступного разу ви збираєтеся
розпочати нову тему добре дякую
за увагу до зустрічі  наступного разу до побачення
[музика].